grab your loot and shoot some Nazis
because we have the latest episode of
Wes world in this video we're gonna take
a deep dive into episode 2 uncovering
its many Easter eggs hidden details in
theories about what the heck is really
going on and you'll want to stick around
till the very end is I'll be going over
who exactly anger on serac is and how he
may be the key to saving all of humanity
welcome to war world but will later find
is a simulation of 1943 Italy but even
though you may think it's a simulation
it appears to be based off an actual
dello spark this is discover war world
calm which says the park is currently
undergoing maintenance so if you're
looking to kill Hitler you may have to
wait a bit the episode begins where we
left off in the post-credits scene from
episode 1 where may finds this bloodied
and bruised German she apparently
tortured judging by the bruises on her
fist
she's interrupted by Hector or in
Italian authority who has a romantic
history with Maeve dating back to season
1 he's taken on a new role as a partisan
against the occupying fascist forces but
she thinks he's there to help her escape
the park
she'll later find that he's simply been
reprogrammed into a new narrative called
the Fuehrer's Fuhrer which sees Maeve's
British spy character and Hector tried
to warn the Allies that their upcoming
offensive will lead them into a trap I
can't really play the music here but if
you play close attention you'll hear a
distorted version of the west-world
theme hinting at the eventual reveal
that this isn't reality at all rather a
simulation but we'll get into that in a
bit
stopping on their way out of this
medieval like town which was actually
shot in Bessel ooh Spain Maeve tries to
user Jedi you will let us pass powers
which don't work on the Nazi hosts
another hint that something about this
place is a little off since May even
season two was able to control the hosts
her plan B is to literally shove a
cyanide pill into a Nazis face in order
to make her escape add that to my list
of ways to kill a Nazi and I want my
scouts Hector leads her to a vintage mg
sports car a British made vehicle which
makes sense since Maeve's character here
is a British spy he tells her they'll
make their escape via the air but Maeve
realizes he's been reprogrammed after he
calls her Isabella her name in this
narrative there
a fun not to season one when she tells
them to hand over the secret plans to
the Nazis because quote they're as empty
as the safe you used to chase harkening
back to how his characters narrative in
Wes world involved him stealing a safe
Hector is shot in the scuffle leaving
Maeve alone to confront the reality that
she is in yet another endless loop so
she ends up shooting herself to
essentially restart back at the Mesa
where she'll be repaired and hopefully
find some answers back in the real world
we get another one of these circular
divergences which we saw in episode one
we're in the South China Sea where
Bernard has chartered a boat to take him
to the now abandoned West world
abandoned because of the massacre which
occurred there last season these
circular screens here I believe are the
work of Rehoboam we see the same
circular feature when Maeve wakes up in
socks home later in the episode serac
will find is the other partner that
created Rehoboam alongside Liam
Dempsey's father years ago the fact that
it says divergence hints that Bernard is
taking a path he wasn't meant to take
since Rehoboam is an AI that can choose
one's path for them it's picking up this
anomaly will also later find the tablet
Maeve uses to hack into the simulation
has the same white and black type look
and feel to it as these intro screens
providing further proof that row warm
serac and these diversion screens are
somehow related we get this beautiful
shot of Westworld from a distance and
I'm not gonna get into the logistics of
how they made this whole thing in the
middle of the South China Sea but
knowing how they have these giant
terraforming machines i think the show
wants us to extend our disbelief here
bernard visits the old town which played
a role in season one and it looks as if
everything is burned from the events of
season two but this was actually caused
by California wildfires Maeve awakens at
the Mesa to be repaired when she finds
Felix Lutz who was with her in Shogun
world last season he however doesn't
seem to recognize her nor does Sylvester
for that matter which adds up to her
suspicion that something is off about
this place fun fact Felix and Sylvester
are both named after the cartoon cats of
the same name but what really throws me
for a loop is the reveal that head of
narrative lee Sizemore who sacrificed
himself last season so she could get
away is
still alive he says he reprogrammed
Maeve to be in war world because it's
closer to the forge the place will later
see them travel to and that he says can
open the portal to the sublime so that
she can be with her daughter this is
really important because it plants the
idea and Maeve's mine that she might be
able to finally be with her daughter the
thing she wants more than anything this
is likely what Ciroc will use his
leverage to get her to join his side
this promise to reunite the two bernard
goes to Ford's secret cottage stopping
for a moment at the blood-stained of the
wall where he killed the head of quality
assurance Teresa Cullen in season 1 in
the basement he finds several broken
versions of himself along with a
malfunctioning Stubbs who Bernard yet
doesn't know is a host Stubbs was
programmed by Ford to cover Bernards
tracks to give him a fighting chance to
escape and with his mission over he
attempted to kill himself by blasting
his c6 vertebrae the explosive put in
every host that goes off if they ever
leave the island Bernard tells him that
he needs to find MAME who may be the
only one to stop Dolores but why would
Dolores bring back Bernard if he's only
gonna get in her way
Bernard theorizes that he may have been
brought back because she knows she might
go too far and he will act as a
counterbalance to that something tells
me this isn't the real reason and
there's something much deeper at play
here Stubbs tells Bernard he'll take him
to Maeve as maid once again wakes up in
her loop she leaves Hector behind this
time who really is hopeless due to his
programming and meets up with Lee who
takes her to the forge Lee thinks that
it was Maeve who operated the cannons
last season that opened the sublime but
we all know that was Dolores and in a
really weird departure from character he
professes his love to her and goes in
for a kiss which Maeve is like
this kissing scene is a reference to the
1976 sequel to West world the movie
future world where Delos has been
copying the DNA of its guests in order
to make clones of them one of the
characters in that film kisses another
to determine whether he's a clone or not
just like how Maeve is able to determine
that Lee isn't real after she kisses him
in fact when Maeve calls Lee out as
being fake he can't wrap his head around
it and he starts to malfunction the
screen here turns anamorphic with these
black bars at the top and bottom which
was the same style used in season 2 to
depict a simulation stub leads Bernard
to a decommission me which was really
hard to find clips for the scene since
most of them had boobs or wieners all
they defined the pearl which contains
her data has been taken out if he's
gonna find where she is hilling access
to add ellos terminal in order to reach
the mainframe in Lee's office may
theorizes that someone is testing her to
find out what she knows the world are in
right now isn't a world at all it's a
simulation within a simulation and
because of that it can be overloaded
sidenote for those keeping track this is
now the second time the notion of a
simulation within a simulation has been
tossed around the first time being the
party scene in Episode one and knowing
Jonathan Nolan is one of the executive
producers brother of Christopher Nolan
who did inception dream within a dream
I'm beginning to think they may be
playing with this idea on a broader
scale but back to the simulation being
overloaded after she asked these two
employees with the square root of
negative one is the question makes them
work their brains so fast that for a
brief moment it freezes the simulation
this math question is a reference to one
of the biggest unsolved problems in
mathematics the Reimann hypothesis which
I won't get into or else my brain will
explode if Maeve can recreate this same
effect but on a broader scale perhaps
she can find a way out Stubbs brings
Bernard to the medieval world portion of
the Mesa where we get a brief cameo from
David Benioff and DB Weiss the executive
producers of another little HBO show you
may remember or not want to remember
Game of Thrones they're playing texts
just waiting to be laid off just like
how they got played off on the new Star
Wars trilogy they make mention that the
dragon here which looks awfully like
drogon was bought by some startup in
Costa Rica a fun nod to Jurassic Park
Bernard is able to connect to the
mainframe where he experiences flashes
of Dolores in the library where data on
the park guests were collected by del
O's when the books as the named Liam
Dempsey on it the same guy who was
seduced by Dolores and whose father
created Rio Boehm and in one of the
wackiest West world moments in the
entire season Stubbs is somehow able to
fight off multiple armed guards with
just a medieval axe that I can't explain
Mae wakes up Groundhog Day style back in
the same loop but this is all part of
her plan Mae planted multiple spy papers
in all of the Nazi uniforms while
up in the Mesa so that when she'd awaken
in the narrative it would so mess up
everyone's processing so much so that
the entire simulation would have no
choice but to freeze she uses the
opportunity to infiltrate the network
and gain access to the security cameras
and drones of the company that's doing
this to her it's interesting to note
here that time in the simulation runs
faster than in the real world just like
dreams run faster than the real world in
Inception the robot made common deer's
was known as Harriet by the production
crew and was actually motion captured in
Spain she uses it to retrieve her pearl
which is enclosed in this white casing
pearls are what Delores used to smuggle
out some of the host data at the end of
season two as the drone makes its escape
you can hear on the intercom a
containment breach announcement both in
English and Spanish leading me to
believe since it was also shot there
this is somewhere in Spain but they
might make it Los Angeles for the
purposes of the show since most of the
other characters are there poor Harriet
meets a tragic end but this isn't the
end of Maeve's journey this season just
the beginning
Bernard tells Stubbs that he needs to
find Liam Dempsey who may hold the key
and unlocking this whole mystery he also
programmed Stubbs to essentially be his
personal bodyguard so expect them to
make it to California fairly soon Mae
wakes up in surak's mansion this guy
here he created were hobo him along with
Liam Dempsey senior and it was implied
last episode by Dempsey jr. that serac
was the one responsible for his father's
death notice how both Maeve and Ciroc
are wearing white black and white have
been used extensively throughout the
series to separate good from evil
characters the man in black aka William
being one that comes to mind contrast
their colors to what Dolores wears for
much of episode one black the costuming
would suggest serac may've good Dolores
bad Caleb will be caught between this
light and dark quite literally in the
opening sequence of episode 1 we see him
straddling this line serac tells made
that a war is waging that has already
been lost a quite cryptic line that
suggests Iraq's ownership of Rehoboam
has given him insight into the future
but Rehoboam has stopped working
something is disrupting it something he
initially thought was Maeve hence the
whole simulation ruse so he tasked her
with taking Dolores the real disruption
out
I mean what better warrior than someone
who is able to change her own code
rewrite her own story and just took on a
bunch of Nazis he tells her that their
interests are aligned but she takes the
opportunity to try and kill him only to
be stopped by this remote control
remember he owns her pearl and likely
made a copy of her host body and
inserted it into it with the ability to
control her functions with this and
likely a way for her to reunite made
with her daughter as incentive will
likely seem a falling in line to put an
end to Delores for good thank you for
watching everyone please make sure to
LIKE and subscribe as I'll be doing
breakdowns for each episode and if you
want to change a pace and wash out that
Game of Thrones cameo check out my how
Game of Thrones should have ended video
I want to hear your thoughts and
theories about the show in the comments
below and feel free to follow me on
twitter at things story whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much